In Ukraine,
the price of food jumped 55%,
vegetables are 32% more expensive and on these shelves
south cost up to three times more than just a few months ago.
I am at the supermarket in Western part of Ukraine where we can see how the war
has affected daily lives of Ukrainians beyond deadly fighting
and destruction in supermarkets.
Now it's hard to afford even basics.
The war in Ukraine has pushed up prices around the world,
but inside the country,
inflation is much higher than global figures.
People have been taken to social media to post memes comparing salt to luxury
goods such as diamonds.
It's a big deal because people need salt right now to put away nonperishable food for
the winter,
here's how the war is driving inflation and raising fears of food
shortages.
Ukraine is a major global food producer.
First of War,
the country was responsible for nearly 12% of the world's weed supply
and almost 50% of sunflower oil experts.
Ukraine is also home to one of europe's largest south factories which exported
south to neighboring countries like Romania Moldova and Georgia.
And just like for green and sunflower oil.
The war has disrupted self supplies.
This factory was damaged by shelling in the region and was forced to
shut.
According to a spokesman who told us operations wouldn't restart until the war
is over.
So in supermarkets,
people are likely to continue to find a lot of imported salt which is much
more expensive.
That's hidden.
Some Ukrainians particularly hard with incomes dropping prices of
food going up and uncertainty over supplies.
Many here you sell to pickle lots of vegetables and stock up on food that can
help them survive the winter.
Like most Ukrainians lida has been pickling vegetables for years.
She grows them herself in her garden.
But this harvest season is different.
She's afraid of famine and wants to stockpile food.
The country is still producing some salt.
Ukraine's as a salt.
Mine isn't in the west of the country where fighting has been limited so
far.
The Bahamas,
Southwark,
which virtually remains the only South producer in Ukraine now is operating at
full capacity.
But we can't film there because it's forbidden to film infrastructural objects.
While the war is not over in the near future,
the plan plans to increase production,
but this won't be able to meet the demand of even a quarter of the country,
officials have said,
there won't be a small deficit and the prices are stable.
But that doesn't mean food is or will remain affordable
as the war grants on the economy is expected to shrink by almost half this year
and contribute to keeping the cost of basics high